un match qui tout doux pour plaisir ce
dimanche 30 avril les plaisirs recevez 5
lots du comité de Franche-Comté en
barrage de Fédérale 2 une confrontation
qui se joue sur un match en première
période l'enjeu semble avoir galvanisé
les illinoises déroulaient même 24 à 0
en seulement 22 minutes de jeu il
géreront cet avantage jusqu'à la pose 27
à 3 à la mi-temps
[Applaudissements]
enfin très très belle première mi-temps
on est quand même à 27 3 à la mi-temps
mais bon il y a quand même trois actions
où on doit vraiment se correr et on fait
vraiment des
erreurs techniques qui sont vraiment
évitables et ça c'est dommageables quoi
parce qu'on aurait pu le tuer le match
plus largement en première mi-temps on
les a pris à la gorge tout de suite on
marque en 10 minutes il y a 14-0 on
marque deux fois voilà on a calmé leurs
ardeurs tout de suite et après on a
enchaîné quand on joue comme ça dans
l'avancée en général ça se passe bien au
retour des vestiaires plaisir continue
sur cette dynamique et marque un essai
dès la reprise malgré un relâchement et
trois essais de Saint-Claude des ibinois
se qualifient devant leur public score
final 37 à 23
[Applaudissements]
on est super content parce que c'est la
première fois que le plaisir passe les
phases finales le premier tour les
barrages on a fait une super première
mi-temps avec beaucoup d'intensité je
pense que c'est là qu'on gagne le match
après bon ça a été plus haché il y a eu
un carton rouge en face donc l'arbitre
voilà peut-être un peu compensé mais on
est fier d'être passé contre une équipe
qui était quand même très rugueuse très
heureux de la victoire c'est une
victoire qui valide le travail de
l'année car on aurait été vraiment
traîné dessus de pas passer ce barrage
au prochain tour de ses phases finales
les joueurs affront Saint-Priest dans un
match aller-retour premier match ce
dimanche 7 mai à domicile pour les
plaisirs rois en attendant les joueurs
peuvent savourer